today's super wealthy are richer than
ever and they're giving away their
billions like never before Facebook
founder Mark Zuckerberg promising to
give away 99% of his shares of the
company to charity philanthropists are
putting record sums into tackling the
world's most pressing problems of
compassion and unlike the mega donors of
the past
today's philanthropists want to see the
results in their lifetimes Michael
Bloomberg's philanthropy is a gift to
this planet but how altruistic is this
new golden age of Giving have these mega
donors become too powerful we have
created a separate and unequal system
where billionaires go influence it by
just buying social change the way
charities work is increasingly under the
microscope a long-delayed reports into
sexual abuse by Oxfam workers in Haiti
we're in non-violently
donas large and small a demanding better
bang for their buck Caroline 103 nitiram
rock form this is leading to innovative
new approaches to doing good which are
redefining notions of altruism 100
million dollars has been given thanks to
the effective altruism
you
Manhattan New York other pathways belts
if you need any services we take a car
just in case
Hilton Douglas is an outreach worker for
urban pathways a nonprofit benefiting
from a recent explosion in charity
amongst wealthy Americans and Hilton is
on a mission to tackle one of the
country's toughest problems one rough
sleeper at a time there are record
numbers of homeless people in New York
and every day Hilton tries to help some
of the worst affected hagel sir there's
a card that's the drop-in center in 2018
spending by charitable foundations
reached a record seventy five billion
dollars in America the charity Hilton
works for is one of 250 that are backed
by New York's largest and best-known
foundation Robin Hood Robin Hood
provides a small percentage of urban
pathways total income but the foundation
also donates strategic and operational
assistance having the support of funders
is essential they have up wasn't for
Robin Hood I'm not sure where would be
at at this particular time
put your feelings
urban pathways runs outreach programs in
a drop-in center and provides a roof for
around 850 men and women each night it
can be dangerous other people in the
street and take advantage Rufus has been
on the streets for six years good news
for you
and I've a placement for you at the safe
haven today today we're going to do it
today so you finally can walk the
streets and give your chapter a new
chapter alright for long-term rough
sleepers like Rufus the charity has set
up three safe havens as an alternative
to city funded dormitory-style shelters
[Music]
officers lost contact with his family
and is hoping his temporary home could
help turn his life around don't own yet
you have to act hard when you're not on
there are a lot of cutthroats heard some
time and I see people just just step
over somebody they just laid out in the
street and I would love to get back to
work thinking for myself I can get back
with my family in there and that's my
family
the ultimate aim is to get Rufus and
other homeless people into permanent
affordable housing hilton believes the
Robin Hood Foundation is helping his
charity find a long-term solution to New
York's homelessness crisis and say if I
wasn't here there might be two hundred
plus more people on the street that you
might be stepping over so Robin Hood is
saving lives because I'm saving lives
[Music]
[Music]
every year Robin Hood stages America's
biggest glitziest fundraising gala where
it raises over 60% of its annual funding
in three hours
whatever amount that you feel whether it
be a hundred dollars to house a family
for one night that they otherwise would
be homeless while the average annual
donation to the foundation is a hundred
and eight dollars the gala has helped
Robin Hood become renowned as the
charity of choice for hedge fund
managers and bankers over the past 30
years it's raised and spent around three
billion dollars fighting poverty in New
York we've helped hundreds of thousands
of people change lives improve lives
Paul Tudor Jones founded Robin Hood an
investor in hedge fund manager worth
around five billion dollars he believes
private philanthropy leads the state in
dealing with society's problems if we
had a perfect world where governments
were going to actually act in the best
interest to people were they actually
going to represent and what local
communities need
and address those problems then no we
wouldn't have a need for philanthropy
but that unfortunately is not the case
the innovation as it does in virtually
everything in the world comes from the
private sector and then quite often as
either sanctioned and/or adopted by the
public sector I don't think fighting
poverty is any different real altruism
for most people at the Robin Hood gala
would be to stop doing business the way
they do business journalist Anna and
Gary Derrida's spent three years
exploring the motivations of America's
wealthy philanthropists he is concluded
that some of their business practices
create the very social problems their
philanthropy tries to address what I see
is a roomful of people who think they
are helping but are working at much
greater scale to maintain and entrench a
system that frankly dooms the people
that they're helping real altruism would
actually be doing less harm not running
working people into the ground through
the pressure they put on the companies
they take stakes in in the past 30 years
the number of foundations in America has
almost tripled since 1978 the proportion
of overall giving has come from those
foundations has also tripled but the US
Treasury estimates philanthropy will
cost it seven hundred and forty billion
dollars in lost tax revenue over the
next decade Anand claims this giving by
wealthy Americans is more about tax
breaks than charity poor people people
who make twenty thousand dollars a year
are paying higher taxes than they
otherwise would to subsidize about fifty
billion dollars in tax breaks every year
that we give people for donating money
you are injecting harm into the society
you are making more money and then you
are going to the Robin Hood gala to
donate 1% of what you have stolen from
the
good to a fraction of the people whose
interests you have harmed and you feel
so proud of yourself
it's an arsonist convention in which
everybody is under the mistaken
impression that their firefighters while
some are questioning the motivations
behind large charitable donations others
are taking action to stop what they see
as tainted philanthropy it's Monday
night in London a group of activists are
protesting outside one of the city's
most prestigious art galleries they are
angry that the National Portrait Gallery
is sponsored by BP one of the world's
leading fossil fuel companies do you not
think those could be much better
[Music]
one of the group's founders Danny
Cheevers has chosen the opening night of
a new exhibition to chain himself to the
gallery's railings
eep-eep gets to associate itself for
this great artist to associate itself
with his leading artists gets to present
itself as this sort of positive company
that's doing something useful in the
world when in reality it's actively
lobbying spending tens of millions of
pounds every year blocking climate laws
slowing down the growth of renewable
energy making the world a much more
dangerous place for everybody and in the
middle of a climate crisis the idea of
taking money or in fact helping to
promote on oil company just seems more
and more in defensible since 2012
these protesters have been invading
spaces in performing guerrilla theater
like this protest against BP sponsorship
of the British Museum
[Music]
they call themselves BP or not BP and
described themselves as a theatrical
protest group of activists the methane
is rising and killing us tonight protest
is another attempt to shame a major arts
institution into refusing philanthropic
money from big oil institutions need to
actually have a conversation with
themselves and with their stakeholders
and with their publics and with their
star about what are their values and
what are the ethical red lines any of
the guests don't seem to agree with the
protesters I think the sponsorship of
something like this has helped artists
immeasurably over the last thirty years
is it at Bingo some feel arts
institutions have little choice but to
accept sponsorship money in an era of
austerity the arts have been
consistently cut by
they have to generate income from other
sources and sponsorship is undoubtedly
one of the sensible ways in which they
can do the gallery security try to
prevent the protesters disrupting the
night but BP or not BP continues the
protest the group argues that for some
major corporations philanthropy is
primarily about whitewashing their
reputations they're buying a cleansing
of their image and they're doing so at a
very cheap price it is not appropriate
for overwhelmingly publicly funded
institutions to be laundering the images
of corporations that are working
actively against the public interest
around the world revered arts
institutions are now questioning the
sources of philanthropic donations they
receive as in storing the guggenheim
museum to protest the donors alleged
ties to the opioid crisis in 2019 the
guggenheim new york the tate and the
National Portrait Gallery refused grants
from the Sackler foundation because the
Sackler family were widely perceived to
have profited from America's opioid
crisis
in today's world perhaps the most
effective checks on the motivations and
impact of big philanthropy come from
other big philanthropists today
billionaire Michael Bloomberg announced
a 500 million dollar pledge to support
efforts to phase out the nation's
remaining coal-fired plants since 2011
former mayor of New York Michael
Bloomberg has donated over five hundred
million dollars to campaigns to replace
coal with clean energy in the US by 2030
I am pleased to note that Bloomberg
philanthropies is making a pledge of 50
million dollars over the next four years
to support the Sierra Club's new
grassroots beyond call campaign but in
taking on the battle against climate
change mr. Bloomberg has also taken on
other billionaire philanthropists on the
opposing side of the debate the Koch
brothers are among the nation's best
known politically active families the
billionaires network of political action
committees and advocacy groups woodsmen
for decades Oil Barons Charles Koch and
his late brother David have given
billions of dollars to nonprofit
organizations in order to promote
skepticism about global warming well I
give to my foundations is is is all
public information the Koch donations
have had a huge impact on strengthening
the climate change denial Lobby in
America
their money has helped attack scientists
who work in the climate change field
their money has helped underwrite an
army of policy wonks and and lawyers who
poked holes in in different efforts to
regulate greenhouse gas emissions the
cokes have pulled all the levers of
power with their wealth to try to stop
the momentum to regulate greenhouse gas
emissions but Michael Bloomberg's
donations to his campaign beyond coal
have proved an influential
counterbalance so far these have helped
retire 289 coal plants more than half
the country's total Michael Bloomberg's
philanthropy is a gift to this planet
thanks to the coal plants that we have
retired through the beyond coal campaign
the u.s. still has a chance of meeting
its commitments under the Paris climate
agreement even despite Trump its
philanthropy
that's harnessing the will of the
American people and our desire for a
better world for our kids
America has witnessed the spectacle of
its most renowned philanthropists
battling it out over one of the world's
most important political issues the
story of philanthropy and climate change
is the story of kind of billionaire
versus billionaire it's like watching
these Greek gods throw Thunderbolts at
each other you know the cokes versus
Bloomberg and that's increasingly a
story about a lot of issues today that
you'll find billionaires on both sides
of the issue it raises a fundamental
question how much political power should
wealthy but unelected philanthropists
wield
I think Bloomberg is doing great work I
am worried about climate change I also
think Bloomberg has way too much power
for a single individual you can cheer
somebody on in their philanthropy even
as you're concerned about their power in
a society which is supposed to be a
democracy even do quiting even
philanthropy even supporting nonprofits
it is still an exertion of power even
when it's good and the whole point of
modern democracies is to limit the power
of private individuals over public life
that's the whole game that's why we did
this and now we have created a separate
non equal system where billionaires can
also influence it by just buying social
change
[Music]
while powerful and wealthy
philanthropists are increasingly giving
away their money fewer people on average
are giving in the developed world than
two decades ago
a long-delayed reports into sexual abuse
by Oxfam workers in Haiti says it's a
decline that's coincided with scandals
that have rocked some of the world's
best-known charities you not only have
taken people's money you have taken
people's sympathy and you have betrayed
them
little wonder charities are now
experimenting with innovative new
approaches to persuade donors to part
with their cash I am really excited
about tonight I think it's gonna be
great fun in London project manager
Jennifer Johnston is about to give away
her money but she doesn't know how much
not a who I don't even consider myself a
philanthropist ready Jennifer is one of
80 people attending an event organised
by the funding network eret is here have
to compete for donors bids wave cafe's
goal is to set up a vibrant community
arts cafe in North London it's a live
auction with a difference so you put
your hand up and when I point to you you
say your name and the amount you'd like
to give Caroline 100 octopus 100 okay
300 yes Martin one hundred four hundred
Francesca
Franchesca 100 Thank You Jennifer 200 I
was saying about 12 minutes we've
ratcheted up 15 grand charities have
just a few minutes each for their pitch
at an average event the funding Network
raises between 25 and 35 thousand pounds
in about 40 minutes we want to reduce
those maternity deaths and you can help
us please
I have learned my budget already but
that is inherent when you come to
advance notice someone could come along
tonight and contribute 200 pounds but
they will leave saying I was part of a
group of people that raised 30,000
pounds it's a dynamic model of giving
and it's making philanthropists out of
anyone with some cash to spare we
believe we're democratizing philanthropy
something that we all not only can do
but have a responsibility to do and
that's that's what we take great pride
in there's lots of people from different
backgrounds here tonight I think what
we've all got in common is want to
engage in the community in the issues
that the world faces today I feel really
inspired that is the point of the
funding network you come here with your
small contribution to contribute to the
greater good the funding network runs
events across 25 countries worldwide and
hopes to buck the trend in the developed
world of fewer individuals giving to
charity I think it's why it's for Holden
on all of us who are working with in
this area to be transparent to be open
to build trust with our donors and to
look at innovative ways of engaging or
re-engaging people
with rising demand for transparency and
accountability some charities are
offering potential donors a clearer
incentive results mm Catherine kisara I
Dominion it it can kill em it's a small
amount of funding Analia can come Guinea
West Africa the front line in the fight
against a disease that kills over
400,000 people worldwide every year
Cabala lost her two-year-old son to
malaria last year never eaten Dylan
Annie Annie don't wanna be seein Anya
Nadya Kalapana Salalah one Santa de fer
fer McKenna me aitana yamato-kun but
this is also the front line in a new
approach to giving that is rooted in
hard economics here one charity against
malaria Foundation is distributing
mosquito nets
[Music]
in Guinea they've handed out four point
eight million nets this year alone and
they're doing it because by analyzing
data they've calculated this is the most
efficient way to save lives
rather than attracting donors using
marketing techniques that play on
emotion the charity relies instead on
arguments based on hard data it's a
growing model known as effective
altruism effective altruism
is a movement and a philosophy that aims
to use reason and evidence in order to
do the most good possible data is
absolutely fundamental to everything we
do it critically allows us to say how
many nets need to go to each household
so that there is universal coverage
achieves
donors have confidence that we're going
to do what we say we will do so every
two dollars every dollar really counts
effective altruism relies on charity
evaluators which search for and assess
nonprofits that save or improve the most
lives per dollar the charities achieving
the best results are published in a
league table to help donors identify
which will make best use of their money
against malaria foundation is
consistently ranked as one of the
highest for impact and accountability if
we were going to buy a car we would look
at all the different options and try to
work out which is the best suited and
which has best value for money it's
bringing that same scrutiny that we
bring to other you know economic areas
into the charity sector in the past ten
years effective altruism has contributed
over a hundred million dollars in
donations towards against malaria
foundation the charity says this has
helped fund the distribution of 50
million bed nets worldwide protecting 90
million people and saving around thirty
thousand lives economically when you're
ill and suffering from malaria you can't
work you can't teach you can't farm
you really can't function and so it puts
a burden on the economies of these
countries and it's estimated that for
every dollar spent in combating and
fighting malaria through bed nets twelve
dollars is generated in GDP for that
country but effective altruism EA has
its critics who say giving is not a
science and that there is more to
charity than cold hard numbers critics
of EA have said that it appeals maybe to
logic and not emotion and we're here at
a hospital today and there are numerous
young children who are suffering from
severe malaria and you can see worried
parents everywhere I don't see a lack of
emotion in any of that at all
this scientific approach to charitable
giving and work is on the rise and is
assuming innovative new forms it's being
used by some of today's class of
billionaire philanthropists how this
plays out alongside their rising power
will help to redefine the impact of
altruism and how its perceived
you